foreign
[Music]
it's we're the same
in the important ways you know
in every other Universe Gwen Stacy Falls
for Spider-Man
[Music]
and in every other universe
it doesn't end well
it's the first time for everything right
[Music]
excuse me do you have an ATM machine
yeah around here in the Box probably not
changed nothing
it should be simple enough
just make a hole
grab the money
all right
oh that's not right
give me your money where are you
yo what you doing about there man
nothing nothing everything is
everything's cool man all good just
forgot my pin number
please just let me Rob you I'm about to
roll there's no reason to bring wood
into this I've never robbed anybody in
my life please don't make this a bad
experience for me but experience
oh wow the story powder we'll see I'm a
scientists
I
was actually considered handsome by
scientist standards I had a little
accident
I'm so sorry first of all I'm not even
robbing you I mean this hm machine
doesn't even belong to you right this
belongs to the bank they're the real
criminal real criminal you're robbing me
you know I can't really get a job
anywhere anymore being like this so I've
turned to a life of crime why do people
say ATM machine who said that the m
stands for machines
foreign
[Music]
thank you
stop what you're doing and stop
Spider-Man
Miles Morales he's entering sector four
set it do I uh have web on my face
[Music]
let me guess he died
okay miles's grades are pretty good A
and AP Physics that's my little man and
AP Studio Art he takes up his uncle a
minus in English she's a tough grader
and a B in Spanish what oh okay
mommy yes or no it's my fault
I just missed a few classes oh just a
few classes well what's a few I mean you
know like
five five
you're dead my name is Miles Morales I'm
Brooklyn's only Spider-Man and things
are going great so is that a costume
unfortunately for both of us this is
skin oh dang we wanted to be even more
Innovative and unexpected on this film
than we were on the last spider-verse
just when I personally thought it
couldn't get any bigger and better I was
so wrong there's an elite crew with all
the best spider people in it who's the
new guy we start in Miles universe and
he gets to go to all these other worlds
this is unbelievable each has its own
style like it was from a different
artist and also we have a visually
diverse array of spider characters and
there's really unlike anything you've
seen anything is possible in animation
it can look however you can imagine it
it really brings you into the world into
the universe there's folks all over the
world working on this we have this
massive crew of a thousand people
bringing creativity and out of the box
thinking to every shot in the movie the
opportunity is there to tell a story
visually for the scope and scale that's
really difficult to do in live action I
want the full movie experience you can't
mimic that with a movie like this you
gotta go see it on the big screen
Spider-Man across the spiderverse
my name's Miles Morales I'm Spiderman
he's gonna be here any minute give me
your money so are you like a cow or a
Dalmatian ah Spiderman
there's bubbles now hold on
I don't think I want this costume
anymore how's this going miles's grades
are pretty good A and AP Physics that's
my little man and a B in Spanish
[Music]
miles wanna get out of here spider
Society I'm Spiderman oh no way all of
us are
me Miguel O'Hara there's moments in our
stories that are the same for all of us
some good did you bring our baby to
another fight you asked me not to so I
didn't in bed you have a choice between
saving one person and saving every world
I can do both whole station stop
Spiderman you
[Music]
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go nah I'm gonna do my
own thing
does they get any weirder
I guess it can there's nowhere to run
my bad everybody there was somewhere to
run two seconds this film is not get
raided my name is Miles Morales I'm
Brooklyn's one and only Spiderman and
things are going great oh yeah you're
supposed to be here client all right
whatever whatever wow whatever so are
you like a cow or a Dalmatian I am the
spot
that's not funny
don't don't do that
miles's grades are pretty good A and AP
Physics that's my little man and a B in
Spanish
to you and I think you know it
[Music]
miles
wanna get out of here oh when so wait a
minute there's an elite crew with all
the best spider people in it who's the
new guy this is unbelievable this is the
lobby
Miguel O'Hara the whole thing with his
idea
what's the guy I gotta do to join this
spider team you can never be part of
this don't even get me started on Doctor
Strange and a little nerd back on Earth
1999.99 come on go easy on the kid he
had a terrible teacher Peter you have a
baby
I'll take it from here
miles being Spider-Man is a sacrifice
you have a choice between saving one
person
and saving every world
send me home I can't do that I can do
both Spider-Man always always what about
Uncle Ben if not for Uncle Ben most of
us wouldn't be here
[Music]
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go nah
I'm gonna do my own thing
stop Spiderman
[Music]
and then I looked
uh let me guess he died
[Music]
foreign